رجل يرتدي معطف طبيب أبيض
وقناع جراحي، امرأة ترتدي ملابس سوداء
ترتدي الحجاب وشخص ثالث
يحمل كرسيًا متحركًا رأس الحربة،
عملية وقحة لقوات سرية إسرائيلية في
الضفة الغربية، جميع أسلحتهم موسومة
بذلك في تبادل إطلاق نار فوضوي مع
إرهابيين يرتدون ملابس مماثلة  سيعرفون عدوهم،
وسيتحركون كفريق هجوم منسق بعناية
بينما يتبعهم عملاء آخرون
في رجل يرتدي معطفًا بنيًا
وقبعة صلاة بيضاء يوجهون شخصية أخرى
ترتدي ملابس زرقاء بينما يغطس عضو آخر في الفريق يرتدي
بنطالًا أسمرًا في
حقيبة ظهر حمراء وي  ارتدي قبعة سوداء في هذه الأثناء،
يدخل فريق اعتداء آخر بقيادة رجل
يرتدي ملابس نسائية سوداء اللون،
ويتقدم للأمام متجاوزًا شخصًا آخر
يرتدي ملابس سوداء، مما يجبر أحد
العاملين في المستشفى على النزول إلى الأرض، ويسحب سترته
منه، ويدفع رأسه إلى الأسفل
ويغطيها.  مع سترة، يبدو الأمر وكأنه
فوضى منسقة ولكن كل زي
تمويه لإدخالهم إلى المستشفى.
يصل عدد أكبر من الأعضاء إلى 12 عضوًا، ويبدو أن
الأخيرين يتظاهران كزوجين شابين
يحملان حاملة أطفال على الرغم من أنه بالنظر إلى الطريقة التي
يضعها بها حمولة أثقل
من  من المحتمل أن يكون هناك ذخيرة احتياطية لطفل، العميلة
الثانية التي تتظاهر بشخصية
والدة الطفل تأخذ نقطة في
الممر وتوجه سلاحها نحو أي شخص
ربما اكتشف حيلته المعقدة
في أقل من دقيقة،
ولم يتضح ما إذا كانت هذه هي البداية أم النهاية
العملية في هذه الغرفة هي هدفها المحتمل
الدم على الجدران وعلى
الفراش الذي يبدو أنه يشير إلى
حدوث عمليات قتل هنا، تشير وسادة التثبيت إلى
إطلاق نار في الرأس، ويقول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إن الغارة
كانت في الوقت المناسب واستهدفت محمد جلام الذي اقتبس
خططًا لتنفيذ
هجوم إرهابي  والأخوين محمد وباسل
غزة اللذين يزعمان أنهما أعضاء في
حماس والجهاد الإسلامي الفلسطيني،
قد لا يحمي هذا البيان
إسرائيل من اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم حرب
لعدد من التهم بما في ذلك تقديم
أنفسهم كعاملين طبيين
وهو ما يتهم الجيش الإسرائيلي حماس في كثير من الأحيان
بفعله في غزة.  يبدو أن مدير المستشفى
يؤكد أن الثلاثة قد تم إطلاق النار عليهم
معًا، لكنه لا يعطي سببًا
لنوم الثلاثة في المستشفى
على الرغم من أن باسل غزة كان يتلقى
العلاج من إصابة بطائرة بدون طيار في غارة
العام الماضي وكان
[موسيقى]
أصدقاءه مشلولين جزئيًا وأيديهم وعائلتهم ملطخة بالدماء.  يبدو أن
الحداد حول جثثهم انتقل الآن على ما يبدو
إلى أسرة الجناح، مشيراً إلى أن والد محمد جال كان
يعلم أن ابنه كان
هارباً حيث تم نقلهم لدفنهم، حيث كان مسلح
يرافق الكورز، وكان واحد على الأقل من
الرجال المقتولين يحمل سلاحاً آلياً على
صدره تقليدياً في الجنازات  من المرجح أن تؤدي
إعدامات الجهاديين الذين سقطوا، خاصة
وسط اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم حرب، إلى
تأجيج التوترات المتصاعدة. نيك
روبرتسون سي إن إن تل أبيب
إسرائيل